first minister your party the support
Scottish independence you're talking
about cooperation with MPs in the north
of England and in Wales not content with
breaking Scotland out of the UK are you
know penciling political fault lines
elsewhere around the UK and second of
all can ask your reaction to what Boris
Johnson has had to say this morning
they're giving giving the SNP power in a
Westminster government would be like
putting King Herod in charge of a baby
farm
okay I said see you may not like some of
the questions and that is not the fault
of mr. Matthews from Sky and can I see
in response to that first of all I
haven't heard the comments of Boris
Johnson directly this morning so and
it's perhaps not entirely fair of me to
comment on them but if you did say that
then that's an entirely offensive
comment and I think it will be treated
as such not just by people in Scotland
but people across the UK who in my
experience of ordinary people the length
and breadth of the UK did not see
Scotland in that way at all and do not
even see the SNP in that way at all
terms of the first part
in terms of the first part of your
question the the sharp answer is no I'm
not seeking in this election to create
division with or between anybody I make
no secret of the fact that I want
Scotland to be an independent country
but I'm a Democrat Scotland did not vote
to be independent last year and if
Scotland as ever to become independent
than a majority of people in Scotland
need to vote for that in a referendum
right now we remain part of the UK we
remain part of the Westminster system
and therefore my interest is in seeking
to build alliances across the UK for
better politics and for better policies
because that will help people in
Scotland and as a politician I have
spent my entire political career arguing
for what I consider to be in the best
interests of Scotland people will not
always agree that what I argue for it is
in the best interests of Scotland but
that is entirely my motivation so in
this election I am offering to people
elsewhere in the UK a genuine hand of
friendship I'm not trying to hide my
political beliefs as far as independence
is concerned but I am seeing very
clearly we can work together to get the
change that people in Scotland want and
in my experience many many people across
the rest of these islands want as well I
accept the responsibility to be the one
to persuade people in other parts of the
UK that my entreaties in that regard are
genuine and I take that responsibility
seriously
it matters to Scotland to get better
policies at Westminster and if we can
use our voice to do that we benefit
people not just in Scotland but
everywhere across these islands as well